[Générique trop stylé du Golden Moustache]
L'histoire racontée par des chaussettes,
c'est très marrant.
Nous sommes en 1991.
Non non non mais dit qu'on est en 2012 sinon on va pas comprendre.
Non mais on sait qu'on est en 2012, là je raconte l'histoire.
Nous sommes en 1991,
et le jeune Satoshi décide d'aller pitcher une de ses idées incroyables
à un des cadres d'une marque qui commence par Nin et qui fini par do.
C'est ce que nous allons vous raconter dans cet épisode.
Ah, c'était vachement bien.
Bonjour.
Donc, alors, allez-y, parlez moi un petit peu de votre projet, donc de quoi ça parle ?
Alors c'est des monstres,
des monstres mais petits,
mais qui se battent,
entre-eux.
Vous inventez là ?
Non.
Entre-eux,
pour bien savoir qui sera le plus fort des monstres.
Mais,
petits,
mais gentils
entre-eux.
Pas mal.
Voilààà !
Et alors donc, parlez moi plutôt des petits monstres.
Alors en fait, dans mon univers où ça se passe,
ils vivent dans nos poches.
Mais,
dans des boules.
Sinon, ils griffent.
Vous savez comment c'est les monstres,
ça vit, ça coûte cher,
mais gentil.
Oo...kay.
Donc,
ce serait des petits monstres,
Oui.
qui se battent,
Entre-eux.
pour savoir lequel est le plus fort,
Mais petits.
Dans un monde où il n'y a pas d'animaux,
Sauf certains.
et ils vivent dans des boules dans nos poches.
Des vêtements ça coûtent cher
Okay, et alors, comment on les distingue ?
J'ai fait une liste !
Ah, il y a des catégories.
Feu, eau, vent, plante, électricité, glace, combat, poison, sol, vol, psy, insecte, roche, spectre, dragon, ténèbre, acier et normal !
Ouaah !
Ok, pas mal.
Voilà.
Et vous avez développé les personnages des petits monstres ?
J'ai fait une liste !
De ?
Bulbizarre,
Quoi ?
Herbizarre,
De quoi vous parlez ?
Florizarre,
Qu'est-ce qui ce passe ?
Salamèche,
Ah, c'est les noms !
Dracaufeu,
D'aaaccord.
Chenipan,
Okay, je suis avec vous là.
Coconfort,
Roucoups,
Sabelette,
Hum.
Nidoking,
Poissirène,
Mew,
Mew... AAaaaah, j'ai oublié quelque chose !
Le truc le plus important, les petits monstres,
quand ils parlent, ils ne parlent pas,
ils disent leur nom.
Humm.
Par exemple, Dracaufeu dit "dracaufeu dracaufeu"
Salamèche il dit "salamèche salamèche"
Lippoutou il dit...
"lippoutou lippoutou"
VOUS AVEZ FOUILLÉ DANS MES TIROIRS ?!
Non...
VOUS AVEZ FOUILLE DANS MES TIROIRS ?!
Pas du tout.
Non, mais non non, calmez... Je... Pardon, je vous ai coupé, pardon.
Psykokwak il dit quoi ?
Aucune idée
ookay
il dit "psykokwak psykokwak"
Ohhhh ?
Alors j'ai tout bien assimilé, juste pour savoir comment y se comprennent du coup entre eux ?
Au niveau du dialogue.. quand ils se parlent...
Pour se comprendre.
Smogogo,
D'accord.
Mimigal,
M. Mime,
Germignon,
Bon ben c'est vachement bien.
Kangourex,
Togepi,
Kaiminus,
Ça m'intéresse.
Écrémeuh,
Zigzaton,
Ecrapince,
On va pas tous les faire...
Mélokrik,
Rozbouton,
Ceribou...
Y en a beaucoup ?
Non.
Magneti,
Magnezone...
Et c'est ainsi que la réunion dura loooongtemps...
Mais ça valait vraiment le coup. En tout cas d'après des chaussettes.
Xatu,
Natu,
Massao,
Tortipouss,
Dynavolt,
Colhomard,
Solaroc,
Poussifeu,
Coudlangue,
Vigoroth
Dinoclier
Teraclope,
Pikachu...
Non celui-là, je suis pas sûr.
Ouaaah !